palama ministre la parole est à monsieur
jean pierre giran pour le groupe l'est
républicain
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
de nouvelles modalités fiscales ont été
introduits dans les lois de finances
2013 2014 qui conduisent aujourd'hui à
une explosion de la taxe foncière sur
les propriétés non bâties
en effet ces modalités instaure une
majoration plein droit dans la ville de
qatif cadastrales et cela à hauteur de 5
euros par mètre carré en 2015 et 2016 et
10 euros de là alors au delà des
arguments selon lesquels cette mesure
permettrait de libérer du foncier pour
la construction de logements
force est de constater que ces nouvelles
modalités fiscales imposées aux communes
par la loi sont purement confiscatoire
dans ma commune de hyères dans le var
près d'une centaine de propriétaires est
concerné ce qui veut dire d'ailleurs que
les 2000 propriétaires évoqué au niveau
national sont un chiffre qui est
largement dépassé les propriétaires
visés voit souvent une taxation
multiplié par dix par sont parfois par
mille certes ils obtiennent un permis de
construire ou 1/2 d'aménagement avant
ton des années sombres
ils pourront bénéficier d'un dégrèvement
mais que se passera-t-il au niveau de
l'harmonie nos territoires
si pour échapper à cet impôt inique un
permis de construire de 40 ou 50 mètres
carrés est alors déposée sur une
parcelle de 5000 ou 6000 mètres carrés
nord est ont alors le choix qu'entre une
explosion de la taxe foncière sur le non
bâti et un mitage incohérent de l'espace
vous avez indiqué monsieur le premier
ministre qu'il fallait corriger les
effets pervers de cette mesure
je crois qu'il serait plus opportun de
la supprimer
dans tous les cas je vous demande au nom
de propriétaires qui sont très rarement
des nantis de décider sans délai un
moratoire dès cette année afin de ne pas
appliquer cette mesure dans l'attende
une modification ou d'une suppression de
la loi
merci monsieur j rende la parole et à
monsieur christian eckert secrétaire
d'état au budget
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les députés monsieur le député je vous
remercie du ton posé sur lequel vous
avez soulevé cette question
j'aurais néanmoins un point de désaccord
avec vous c'est l'origine de la mesure
l'origine de la mesure ne date pas de
2013 ou 2014
ils datent du mois de mars 2012 le mois
de mars est important chacun l'aura
compris cette disposition a été initiée
par un amendement signé par de nombreux
parlementaires de la majorité
mais cette mesure a évolué dans le temps
elle a évolué de la majorité de l'époque
devait venir
cette mesure a évolué dans le temps elle
a évolué de plusieurs façons le
caractère obligatoire hâtif est devenu
obligatoire
elle a été reportée d'un an sur ma
suggestion d'ailleurs et les professions
agricoles
on a été exclu puisqu'il a été convenu
que les adhérents un régime de mutualité
sociale agricole en étaient exonérés
vous contestez le chiffre de 1700
parcelle concernée je le confirme
néanmoins mais c'est vrai que cette
disposition ne concerne que 618 commune
à l'heure actuelle qui se concentre
d'ailleurs sur quatre départements
85% des dossiers relève de quatre
départements dont le vôtre
les autres étant dans la région
parisienne néanmoins le gouvernement est
conscient qu'il peut y avoir à ce nombre
de difficultés des maires ont parfois
mal transmis les listes des terrains
concernés ils peuvent d'ailleurs aménagé
aménager cette liste et conformément à
l'engagement du premier ministre
même si la mesure répond vous l'avez
d'ailleurs dit même si la mesure répond
à un besoin de libération de foncier
dans des zones tendues dans les textes
financiers que nous aborderons dès les
semaines prochaines
son prêt à discuter avec le parlement de
bolides yannick de modalités
d'aménagement
merci monsieur minutes la parole est à
monsieur rudy